more from the media here the media
basically realizes i think at this point
that written house is innocent um
they're not going to come out and say
that directly but they realize it and
they realize that he should be acquitted
and you know it's pretty good likelihood
that he will be
so now they're looking for a different
narrative
um
a way that their priors on this case can
still be confirmed even if everything
they said about written house is wrong
and chris hayes in his monologue the
other night he thinks he's stumbled on
on what the what the narrative should be
that's the message that was being pushed
to a 17 year old kyle rittenhouse a
child
he heard warnings about the boogeyman of
black lives matter and
antifa and he took this illegally
acquired assault weapon
which he emits not for hunting or for
home defense
and he throws himself at the fray in
kenosha
and he kills two people
the boy
who killed people the boy who killed
people
is then celebrated
by the same pro-gun law and order
culture that produced him as a hero and
a martyr
and he's bailed out with the help of
right-wing activists and he poses for a
photo grinning in the t-shirt of a long
gun themed coffee company
that then courted controversy from the
right when it distanced itself from this
person this boy who'd killed two people
accused of homicide
there's a legal question before the jury
right now of kyle rittenhouse's guilt or
innocence it's being determined will be
determined
from what i've seen i think it's pretty
likely he'll be acquitted honestly
but there's also the broader question of
what kind of society we want to live in
ask yourself that
if you're watching this and you're a gun
owner or or or someone who
considers yourself a defender of the
second amendment abstractly right ask
yourself do we want a society in which
political conflict is settled on the
streets between people with guns
right so
predictable i mean they're nothing
nothing if not predictable but
predictably uh this becomes a case of a
gun culture gone wrong and this is this
is what this is really about and
uh he says in that monologue he
acknowledges that there's pretty good
chance he's gonna be acquitted
and he doesn't say because he's because
he's innocent but that's
you know he he realizes that they all do
there's no getting around it
and so now we're gonna have a
conversation about gun culture
why why was this boy there in the first
place
now by the way now he gets to be a boy
again did you notice that not now he's a
kid
so for a while he was like a grown man
when they thought that they could hang a
murder charge on him he was a grown man
and that's that's what it is but now
that they want to make this about guns
specifically now that they've moved now
that they realize that they're not going
to get the murder thing and now they
want to make it about guns now it's
convenient for him to be a boy a child
again because why is this child have a
gun
so you notice how that switch has
happened
um
and they want to make it a
discussion about gun culture
when of course it isn't
but if you want to talk about
culture as it relates to the kyle
rittenhouse case
well we could do that
um
like the culture in america and in our
cities now
that allows for rampant lawlessness and
rioting
i mean that is what actually led to
everything that happened that night
as i said from the beginning you know
you want to put anybody
on trial
for for what happened in kenosha aside
from all the rioters who should be in
jail almost none of them are almost none
of them were convicted or even charged
with anything
but how about the mayor of the city and
the governor of the state who allowed
this this this to happen
that's what they
we keep hearing how kyle rittenhouse
wasn't supposed to be there he shouldn't
have been there what he was what was he
doing there
and uh we're just supposed to accept
that all of the rioters
rampaging through the streets
burning down buildings
okay so that they're allowed to be there
why was kyle rittenhouse there why was
he actually there
because kyle rittenhouse had
determined
that um
law enforcement was not going to do his
job or was not going to be allowed to do
its job
you know
law in in order had been in kenosha like
in many cities in in in the summer of
2020 lawed order had been abandoned had
been officially abandoned but basically
cancelled it was the purge
now we're not gonna have law and order
and we're just gonna let these these
animals run through the street and do
whatever they want
[Music]
and there were some people who
felt called they felt like they had a
responsibility to step into that void
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated